[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis heute
backen wir eine weihnachtsmann torte
weihnachtsmann tochter schuldig wer
seine studie
naja jedenfalls haben wir heute eine
santa claus also eine weihnachtsmann
torte und zwar city aus wie
weihnachtsmanns bau und nicht nur von
außen sondern auch von innen wenn sie
später nämlich angeschnitten wird das
ist nämlich das besondere an der torte
geschmacklich schmeckte nach zimt und
nach orio keksen da hab ich nämlich eine
schicht schwarzen teig mit eurer keksen
mit drin
nach moratoriums tschuldigung morath
müssen einfach weggedrückt ja jedenfalls
zeige ich erst einmal wie man den teig
erstellt und dann wie man die torte
zusammensetzt
ich denke nämlich irgendwie falsch rum
darum wer meint göbel anders ist jetzt
schauen frauen gürtel branchen frauen
geringer
der weihnachtsmann ist vielleicht eine
weihnachtsfrau eine frau die sich stark
wie nie zuvor hatte morales die wand
soll spass ich weiß ist dass man die
zutaten sind zahlen wieder sicht von
richter werner gesetz gibt das zeichen
für den teig brauche ich 6 301 pries
alles etwas von den extrakt jeweils 300
milliliter sonnenblumenöl und butter
mensch 450 gramm mehl ein päckchen
backpulver
ein teelöffel zimt rote und schwarze
lebensmittel verpasste und ein paar oreo
kekse für den teig nehme ich jetzt die
eier zucker vanille und das salz und
verrisse in 45 minuten richtig cremig
[Musik]
also ist es gebe ich jetzt die zwei
flüssigkeiten bei niedriger stufe mit
dazu
und jetzt kommen noch die trockenen
zutaten mit rein also mehl backpulver
und sind
[Musik]
ein bisschen teil geht es in vier
gleichmäßige betören einteilen kann
werde ich ihnen jetzt abwägen und dann
durch vier teilen also im kopf
ausrechnen und dann nur einen teil
rausnehmen man nur einen teil schwarz
wird der 1600 gramm also eine ziemlich
einfache rechnung das heißt pro portion
sind dann 400 gramm
und zu diesem einen teil kommen jetzt
die zerkleinerten oreo kekse dazu da
habe ich die weiße krähe entfernt und
das ganze richtig fein gemahlen und auch
ein bisschen schwarzer lebensmittel
verpasste und die drei restlichen teile
werde ich dann gleich rot einfärben
[Musik]
und die teiche packe ich jetzt alle
getrennt das 144 ringe und falls ihr nur
einen besitzt sollte die tage
nacheinander machen damit sie nicht
herum stehen und an volumen verlieren
und die haben jeweils einen durchmesser
von 20 zentimetern
[Musik]
streiche immer gerne am rand ein
bisschen hoch dann gehen sie nämlich nur
ein bisschen gleichmäßiger auf
und so werden sie jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 30 minuten gebacken und wenn es
abgekühlt sind werde ich eine
italienische team machen
[Musik]
die teile sind jetzt abgekühlt und ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal eine portion
meiner italienischen mutter creme
gemacht und bei der buttercreme muss man
ganz genau auf die anleitung achten und
da habe ich euch ja schon ein
grundrezept hochgeladen und einen teil
habe ich jetzt hier in einen
spritzbeutel abgefüllt der bleibt weiß
und hat die buttercreme mit bisschen
zimt und vanille extrakt verfeinert so
schmeckt schön weihnachtlich und dem
großen teil werde ich jetzt rot
einfärben mit etwas lebensmittel
verpasste
[Musik]
so sieht die krimis aus und jetzt werde
ich meine tortenböden aus der form
herauslösen
[Musik]
ist nämlich zuerst einmal den spatzen
kuchen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier zwei
ausstecher diesen rund und falls jetzt
keine runden ausschüsse habt könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch ein glas nutella oder
sonst irgendwas rundes nehmen und
braucht jetzt einen kleineren und einen
größeren die lege ich jetzt hier mit ich
drauf und die müssen wirklich sehr mutig
sein und dann ausstechen
diesem inneren kreis brauche ich es
nicht es kann weg das kann man so
forschen und dieser kleine greife etwa
zwei zentimeter im durchmesser kleiner
als der größere
jetzt legt sich den schwarzen kuchen auf
den roten einfach um die perfekte
position zu haben und stellt hier
nochmal so leicht rein aber nur etwa 5
mm tief und kann jetzt hier diese fünf
millimeter wegnehmen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier alle viel kuchen den
zweiten roten habe ich auch so
ausgeschnitten und ausgestochen und
jetzt gehts los mit dem gefühl und
stapeln und zwar brauche ich jetzt die
weiße creme und die komplizierten diese
vertiefung 1
hier außen auf die rote fläche streiche
ich jetzt etwas kaputt
[Musik]
dann kommt da jetzt der schwarze große
ring drauf und der kleinere mittenrein
und die freie fläche die jetzt hier am
rand entsteht die muss ich jetzt auch
mit weiß auffüllen
[Musik]
und auch die oberfläche mit weiß
aufhören
[Musik]
den rand bestreite ich jetzt erneut mit
rot und setzte dann den anderen teil mit
der aushöhlung obendrauf
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch mal eine schicht
droht und dann setzt den vierten tag
deckel obendrauf
[Musik]
jetzt bestreitet die komplette torte mit
einer richtig dünnen schicht buttercreme
damit die krümel ein bisschen gebunden
werden
dann stelle ich sie kühl und streicht
sie mit der restlichen film ganz schön
sein
[Musik]
bevor die volland decke jetzt auf die
torte kommt kann ich schon mal ein
bisschen torten dekoration vorbereiten
und ab jetzt ein stück schwarze blüten
passt weiß geknetet und die rolle ich
jetzt 3 mm dünn aus das geht am besten
mit zwei kölnern dann wird es nämlich
ganz gleichmäßig und blüten passt
nämlich jetzt weil die schön durch
trocknet und weil ich die elemente
daneben gleich auch für die torte weiter
verwenden kann
habe ich das auch nur matte gelegt denn
da kann ich später auch darauf trocknen
lassen und werde zwei ausstecher
benutzen und zwar sind die von der größe
her so dass sie seit kleinere ausstechen
der hat die maße 4 cm x 23 und der große
hat die maße vieren hartmann
sechseinhalb und zwar wird es jetzt die
schnelle des stechens einmal im großen
aus dann noch die kleinen
und jetzt fahre ich noch dem
gürtelschnallen stift wenn das dach ist
falls nicht dürfte quizfrage und ihr
tipp führen wir gerne beantworten
[Musik]
und damit dieser gürtelschnallen stift
ein bisschen echt aussieht werde ich dir
jetzt um vorne ein bisschen erhöhen und
dann so antrocknen lassen
und während die zwei schnell unter
gürtelschnallen stift hier an trocknen
kann ich schon mal die torte mit roten
von dann überziehen
die tat ist gut durch gekühlt und jetzt
werde ich sie mit roten fondant
einkleiden dadurch jetzt 57 gramm
bereits weit geknetet roll den funden
auf becker stecken dann über die torte
[Musik]
jetzt historische eingedeckt und stellt
sich etwa eine stunde in den kühlschrank
bevor dann die decke drauf kommt jetzt
manchmal auch die dekoration für die
torte fertig und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier schon ein weißes stück von land
ausgerollt und lange und dünn ausgerollt
denn ich möchte hier unten einfach so
eine bordüre machen braucht da ein band
und das schneiden jetzt mit dem bisschen
schön gleichmäßig aus ansonsten nehmen
da einfach ein messer oder marzipan
messer oder auch einen pizzaschneider
und das alles tätig jetzt mit etwas
essbarem kleber hier unten an
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt noch ein etwa 4 cm
breites schwarzes band das habe ich
jetzt aus modelle schokolade gemacht
denn modelliert schokolade ist ein
business fester und lässt sich super
einfach verarbeiten und das wird jetzt
nämlich der experte
[Musik]
und damals mit immer so eine markierung
bei 3 cm etwa damit ich dieses band
einfach auf die richtige höhe platzieren
und aufklärung
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt noch der gürtel abschluss
dafür nehme ich jetzt noch mal dieses
stück schneider vorne so eine kleine
rundungen rein und steckt ein kleine
löcher aus und die mache ich dann
einfach mit einer spritztour
[Musik]
die gürtelschnalle ist jetzt auch
getrocknet und diebe streiche ich jetzt
gleich mit etwas gold bruder aber werde
die schnelle ein bisschen mit wasser
bestreichen dann haftet das gold wieder
ein bisschen besser
[Musik]
witten sind die teile nur noch an der
torte befestigt werden
und jetzt muss der gürtelschnallen stift
einmal durch das loch und dann kann man
den sie so befestigen
ich glaube den orten präsent weg
[Musik]
9 itate anschneiden ja samira hatte
wichtig ist natürlich dass man die mitte
trifft weihnachtsmann
das land ist riesengroß
nikolaus nikolaus große richtige
nikolaus vor langer langer langer zeit
ist lange räumen guck mal wie das
aussieht
das sieht aus wie wie sieht das aus
angeschnitten cool denn ich schreibe
jetzt gleich noch richtig an also noch
ein viertel raus aber ich finde sie
musste erst einmal mega cool oder
schweizer börse machen so kuchen mit
muster innen drin beim anschnitt weil
von außen finde ich die torte sehr schön
und scheinbar unscheinbar und dann
schneidet man sie auch unfällen
also die schwarze schicht ist die orior
schicht und die rote shift ist ganz
normal mit ihm vielleicht man kann
natürlich auch die restliche creme der
orion einfach mit in die italienische
buttercreme mit rein nehmen und die ela
kommt auch dann wenn es zu essen gibt
und schmeckt gut wie oreo creme hosen
findet aber fast sogar mit vanille herz
habe viel vanille in die buttercreme
rein und sims deswegen schmeckt wie oreo
ich würde mal gerne die kamera einzeln
das ist richtig das ist richtig saftig
merkt es ist richtig freute kuchen und
die kritischen verfassung mehr krems
angriffsfläche das muss auch dazu sagen
ich mochte früher gar keine buttercreme
und mittlerweile ist die buttercreme
einer meiner lieblings krems und zwar
die französische und die italienische
weine einfach noch ein mit drin hat hier
in dem fall eiweiß und die schmeckt
wirklich so glaube ich amerikanische
nicht die amerikanischen die spitze ist
aber die schmeckt mir richtig gut vor
allem kanada zimt und vanille mit
reingeben perfekt und die idee zu der
torte haben übrigens von einer
zuschauerin die haben uns nämlich ein
foto auf facebook geschickt hat gesagt
rally hin dass durch diese torte nicht
mal nachmachen und da war gerade dieser
ebenso centers weltkrieg genau das
center also weihnachtsmann bauch torte
und deswegen darf ich die idee her und
habt ihr dann für euch nach gemacht
falls jetzt auch lust auf das rezept
bekommen habt geht auf salehs - block
der etat steht noch immer ganz genau ich
finde es ist eine torte die macht
einfach auf
und wer macht sich exakt an die
anleitung hält dann gelegt auch genau so
wie bei mir hier mit bisschen übung
schafft ihr das auch alle und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und schöne weihnachten und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
als ich aus wie der weihnachtsmann
dankeschön
[Musik]
wir heißen dieses ding beim gürtel da
fast nur so rein piekst wenn das sicher
die gürtelschnalle
und wie heißt der andere teil der reihe
wie heißt das ok quizfrage wie heißt
dieser rein pixar im gürtel das stift
okay und jetzt fahre ich noch den
gürtelschnallen stift finde ich ist